[Musique]
merci Max Brisson de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu des Pyrénées Atlantiques
membres du groupe les républicains et
vice-président de la commission de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
communication vous avez auditionné hier
Gabriel hatal on va longuement en parler
tout à l'heure mais d'abord on va parler
d'Israël Emmanuel Macron qui reçoit à la
mi-journée les chefs de parti il prendra
la parole ce soir dans une allocution à
20h qu'est-ce que vous en
attendez d'abord une la nation mais elle
a déjà été faite au plus haut niveau par
le chefs de l'État par le
gouvernement par le président du Sénat
nous venons de l'entendre ce qui s'est
passé dans un certain nombre de kibuts
du sud d'Israël ça parente tout
simplement un crime contre l'humanité
c'est du terrorisme c'est de la barbarie
la condamnation doit être équivoque le
Sénat hier a été très digne toutes les
forces politiques le Sénat dans son
unité à condamné et s'est déclaré
solidaire du peuple d'Israël c'est
déclaré solidaire de la démocratie
israélienne et ceci d'ailleurs en
présence de l'ambassadeur d'Israël à
Paris ambassadeur d'Israël que vous avez
d'ailleurs rencontré un peu plus tôt
dans la journée d'hier avec d'autres
sénateurs quelle a été la teneur de cet
échange la teneur de cet échange a été
dans la même veine que ce qui s'est
passé l'après-midi dans l'hémicycle
l'ensemble des des groupes politiques
étaient représentés il s'agissait de
dire que l'on peut bien sûr être
critique avec le gouvernement israélien
mais que le peuple israélien a le droit
de vivre sur le sol d'Israël et
queisraël est une démocratie et que
lorsqu'une démocratie est attaqué c'est
le cœur de toutes des démocraties qui
saignent le président Larcher a rappelé
à cet instant que lorsqu'en 2015 avait
eu lieu à Paris les attentats barbares
que l'on connaît et bien le président de
la knisset avait indiqué au président du
Sénat que le cœur d'Israël est pleuré le
président Larcher a dit la même chose à
l'ambassadeur d'Israël lui disant qu'il
allait écrire au président d'AC deset
pour dire que le cœur de la France
pleure dans ce moment où la démocratie
où nos valeurs ou tout ce que nous avons
à partage est attaqué par la barbarie
les attaques commises par le Hamas ce
sont des crimes contre l'humanité pour
vous je n'ai pas les qualifications
juridiques pour comme l'a dit la
ministre de des Affaires étrangères pour
qualifier cela mais je le crois très
profondément enfin je ne sais pas ce qui
est un crime contre l'humanité si ce
n'est ce que l'on a vu ce que l'on a pu
malheure apprendre depuis les kibuts du
sud d'Israël lorsque l'on sait que des
enfants des des civils des vieillards
des femmes ont été ainsi abatttu de
sansfroid non pas parce qu'ils sont
israéliens mais parce qu'ils sont juifs
c'était un pogromme que l'on a vécu on
ne pouvait pas imaginer qu'en ce début
de 21e siècle on connaîtrait à nouveau
et sur le sol d'Israël ce qui peut
s'apparenter un poromme ce qui est
certainement un crime contre l'humanité
il y a des questions qui se posent sur
les aides dont bénéficie le Hamas on la
a vu hier à Hervé Marseille le président
du groupe Union centriste a posé la
question du rôle du Qatar est-ce que la
France doit clarifier ses relations avec
le Qatar dans ces moments-là il faut
faire front uni et c'est peut-être en
effet temps de sortir de C bre
d'ambiguïé ambigué vis-à-vis d'un
certain nombre de relations avec des
pays qui ne sont pas respectables il
faut ainsi le dire mais également
peut-être aussi à l'Union européenne
doit sortir également d'un certain
nombre d'ambiguïés dans cette situation
tragique l'Union européenne montre
finalement son impuissance les
États-Unis ont réagi les démocraties
européennes ont réagi mais la parole de
l'Union européenne est en train de
s'enliser dans des débats Byzantins qui
ne sont pas à la hauteur de l'urgence
nous sommes attaqués quand on attaque
ainsi des familles juives qui vivent en
Israël parce qu'elles sont juives c'est
la démocratie ce sont nos valeurs qui
sont attaqué c'est l'Occident qui est
attaqué il faut le dire sans ambiguïé et
par exemple on peut s'interroger en
effet sur le détournement de l'aide
européenne par le Hamas aujourd'hui il
aurait fallu la suspendre C je pense
qu'il faut la suspendre Israël de toute
façon est en train d'établir un siège
donc je pense qu'aucune aide ne passera
c'est pas la décision prise par l'Union
européenne ben c'est l'Union européenne
a eu tort à force d'ambigué à force de
technocratie faut pas s'étonner ensuite
que les peuples européens se détournent
de l'Union européenne qui là est en
train de montrer le visage de
l'impuissance je suis profondément
européen et C attitude de cette pratique
d'Union Européenne me fait beaucoup de
mal on le disait Emmanuel Macron va
recevoir aujourd'hui les chefs de parti
l'ensemble de la classe politique qui
soutient Israël condamne les attaques
terroristes du Hamas sauf Alfi qui
refuse de parler de terrorisme qu'est-ce
que ça dit selon vous ça dit d'abord que
l'antisémitisme a toujours existé à
l'extrême gauche depuis proudon
fourriier et d'autres
vousantiside en tous les cas Jean-Luc
Béchon s'il n'était pas antisémite a
perdu quelques occasions depuis 72
de nous le montrer ces ambiguïés
permettent en effet de poser cette
accusation et lorsque l'on est ambigu
vis-à-vis de l'antisémitisme on
n'appartient plus à l'arc républicain et
actuellement c'est bien ce qui est en
train de se faire à force d'ambigué un
certain nombre des leaders de LFI et le
principal d'entre eux ont ont perdu de
belles occasions de bien montrer qu'ils
étaient dans l'arc républicain et qu'il
y a des moments où il faut sortir de
l'ambiguïé tout ne peut pas être utilisé
pour des questions de politique
politicienne et tout ne peut pas être
utilisé partir par cliantellisme
politique oui bien sûr Jean-Luc
Mélenchon s'est enfermé dans une posture
qui a au départ est tactique et
politicienne tant il n'a pas voulu
sortir mais en en sortant pas il a passé
de belles occasions de bien montrer que
vis-à-vis d'antisémitisme il n'y avait
pas d'ambiguïé malheureusement c'est
bien le contraire qui s'est produit
depuis samedi on va continuer à parler
de ce sujet puisque ça fait partie des
thèmes que vous avez abordé hier avec
Gabriel Atal le ministre de l'éducation
nationale que vous auditionniez pour la
première fois depuis sa nomination à ce
ministère on va regarder les temps forts
de cette audition avec Samia de
[Musique]
chia bonjour Samia bonjour Orian bonjour
Max Brisson bonjour et Samia vous avez
suivi hier la longue audition de Gabriel
àal devant le Sénat oui une très longue
audition qui duré plus de 2h30 et comme
c'était évidemment sa première audition
en tant que ministre de l'éducation
nationale devant les sénateurs et bien
ils avaient plein de questions à lui
poser parmi les nombreux sujets évoqués
hein celui des conséquences du conflit
vous venez d'évoquer le conflit en cours
entre Israël et le Hamas à l'école
Gabriel hatal a confirmé que le
ministère a reçu ces derniers jours
plusieurs alertes d'agression et
d'intimidation d'élèves de confession
juives en lien avec le conflit en cours
il promet de se montrer intraitable
regardez j'ai demandé hier que
systématiquement quand il y a des faits
de cette nature ça remonte au ministère
systématiquement deuxièmement j'ai
demandé qu'il y ait systématiquement
saisine du procureur de la République
qu'il y ait plainte ou qu'il n'y ait pas
plainte le ministère saisira le
procureur de la République euh et
évidemment des sanctions disciplinaires
à l'endroit des élèves donc je passe le
message de manière très claire je l'ai
fait ce matin des élèves qui
intimideraiit menaceraiit agresseraiit
ou envisagerait de le faire des
camarades des élèves de confession
juifes
devrait avoir peur alors c'est vous he
Max Brisson qui avez interrogé Gabriel
Atal sur ce sujet vous l'avez aussi
interpeller sur un autre sujet celui des
tenues des accompagnants des sorties
scolaires je rappelle que vous êtes
l'auteur d'une proposition de loi qui
prévoit entre autre une obligation de
neutralité pour ses accompagnants de
sortie scolaire Gabriel Attal n'est pas
d'accord avec vous on regarde tout de
suite la réponse qu'il vous a fait hier
avant de vous laisser
réagir autant j'ai une détermination
absolue et j'assume totalement la
décision que j'ai prise sur
l'application de la loi 2004 dans
l'école de la République qui a été
validé par le Conseil d'État qui s'est
prononcé sur le fond autant sur ce
sujet-là j'assume aussi la décision qui
est qui est la mienne qui est de ne pas
revenir sur les règles actuellement en
vigueur j'entends que ça puisse faire
des BAT qui des propositions différentes
qui viennent de groupes politiques mais
j'assume ma décision alors avant de vous
entendre Max Brisson juste une précision
la décision que le ministre a pris en
s'appuyant sur la loi laïcité de 2004
c'est l'interdiction de laaba pour les
les élèves depuis la rentrée mais ce qu'
a rappelé le ministre aussi hein c'est
que la loi et bien ne dit rien pour
l'instant sur les tenues d'accompagnants
des sorties scolaires alors pourquoi
vouloir revenir là-dessus le ministre
l'a dit hier pour lui ce sont
essentiellement les ma voilées qui
seraient ciblé par votre proposition
est-ce que leur présence dans les
sorties scolaires est un problème pour
vous avant de vous répondre je voudrais
dire un que le ministre a été attentif
il a répondu à toutes nos questions il a
été très ouvert et relativement
performant et je le dis très simplement
vous lui mettez une bonne note oui je
lui mets une bonne note c'est mon côté
ancien prof de deuxièmement sur la
question des la des écoles juive et de
la présence des enfants de confession de
culture juive dans les écoles de la
République c'est j'ai posé éalement la
question j'ai remerci le ministre d' de
s'être rendu à Sarcel dans une école
juive avec le ministre de l'Intérieur
hier matin mais je lu ai aussi demandé
il a très très bien répondu qu'aucun
enfant de confession ou de culture juive
dans les écoles publiques dans les
écoles de la République ne puisse être
inquiété sans que ceux qui auront
provoqué ces inquiétudes soient durement
sanctionnés il a répondu avec
exemplarité mais juste ils sont en
sécurité parce que Gérald armanin qui
dit qu'il y a une cinquantaine d'actes
antisémites depuis samedi il dit
notamment qu'il y a des drones avec
caméras dans les cours d'écolees de
confession juive est-ce que c'est quand
même inquiétant mais c'est inquiétant
qu'il faille de tels dispositifs pour
protéger les enfants juifs qui sont des
enfants français qui vivent dans leur
pays qui vont dans les à école dans leur
pays et il faut que la sérénité existe
dans les écoles juives mais qu'ell
existe aussi pour les enfants de
confession juives dans les écoles
publiques ENF dans quelle société
vivons-nous ou si des petits Français
sont menacés parce que leurs parents
sont de tel ou telle religion là-dessus
il faut être intransigent c'est le cœur
même de la laïité dans ces conditions la
question des accompagnateurs ou
accompagnatrice scolaire n'est pas au
niveau de la tension dans lequelle nous
sommes aujourd'hui et de la gravité des
qui se déroule aujourd'hui et de la
nécessité de ne pas importer dans notre
pays le actuellement ce qui se passe en
Israël et dont j'ai dit tout à l'heure
combien il est c'était condamnable et
combien c'était de l'horreur absolue sur
les accompagnatrices scolaires c'est
intéressant sur le temps long nous
verrons bien si les belles paroles du
ministre se traduisent en acte mais il n
pas d'accord avec vous il n pas d'accord
avec moi mais il va avoir du mal à
justifier que la sortie scolaire c'est
pas la classe c'est pas l'école hors des
murs c'est pas la classe hors des murs
sinon quel est l'intérêt d'une sortie
scolaire c'est n'a pas une une vocation
profondément pédagogique d'ailleurs le
sénateur ouias sénateur communiste lui a
d'ailleurs répondu après moi qu'après
tout lui règlerait la question en
faisant que les sorties scolaires soient
accompagné par des professionnels de
l'éducation on va avoir du mal à ça
coûtera très cher donc je laisse je
laisse pierreouias à sa remarque sauf
qu'il a raison sur un point la sortie
scolaire c'est l'école c'est la classe
et pendant le temps de la classe dans
les murs et hors des murs aucun aucune
personne ne doit manifester son
appartenance religieuse ne doit faire
d'une manière ou d'une autre acte de
prosétisme religieux aucune personne
sinon ce n'est plus la classe et si ce
n'est plus la classe il y a plus aucune
raison que les écoles organisent des
sorties pédagogiques ces sorties sont
pédagogiques ou ne sont pas c'est sont
pédagogiques c'est la classe et j'ai là
une divergence avec le ministre mais
nous en aurons d'autres nous en aurons
d'autres parce que le ministre a de
belles parole il a de fermes intentions
que nous avons plutôt approuvé
finalement il est en train de se
rapprocher de nos positions maintenant
il faudra qu'il traduise cela en acte et
je doute que le en même temps macroniste
et je doute qu'il est vraiment à
l'Assemblée nationale dans la majorité
relative présidentielle suffisamment de
députés par exemple pour le su nous nous
serons prêts à le suivre à condition
qu'il sorte des intentions pour aller
vers les actes alors Samia il y a
beaucoup de sujets qui ont été abordés
pendant cette audition le sujet qui a
fait le plus débat c'est la mixité
scolaire oui il y a une intervention de
Gabriel tal qui a fait vivement réagir
les sénateurs de gauche c'est sa
proposition de faire travailler les
élèves par groupe de niveau en math et
en français au collège alors ça se fait
déjà un petit peu hein depuis la rentrée
en réalité au collège puisqu'on a
supprimé une heure de technologie pour
les élèves de 6e et cette heure elle a
été remplacée par une heure de soutien
en mat en France français et cette heure
de soutien elle se fait par groupe de
niveau les meilleurs élèves ensemble et
de l'autre côté les élèves les plus en
difficulté mais ça aujourd'hui ça se
fait juste sur une heure et le ministre
de l'Éducation visiblement et bien il
aimerait généraliser ce dispositif
regardez quand vous avez des élèves qui
ont un niveau tellement différent sur
les mathématiques ou sur le français
dans une même classe vous finissez par
tirer tout le monde vers le bas parce
que ceux qui ont le niveau ne peuvent
plus progresser et les autres n'arrivent
pas à progresser donc moi j'assume de
dire que sur le français et les
mathématiques c'est une piste ça se
regarde c'est pas là une annonce que je
suis en train de faire s'il ne serait
pas opportun de penser une organisation
sur le français et les mathématiques par
groupe de compétences au collège alors
on ne peut pas montrer l'intégralité de
cette intervention mais sachez que par à
la suite de ces propos il y a eu
beaucoup d'agitation dans la salle la
gauche a dénoncé le risque d'une école à
deux vitesses alors faire travailler les
meilleurs collégiens ensemble d'un côté
et puis de l'autre ceux qui qui ont plus
de difficultés pour les maths et le
français he je précise pas pour toutes
les matières est-ce que vous êtes pour
ou contre Max Brisson vous savez
enseigner l'histoographie les sciences
de la vie de la terre dans une classe
marquée par la grande hétérogénité c'est
aussi compliqué qu'enseigner les maths
et les Français donc pourquoi uniquement
pour les maths et les Français je pense
que c'est compliqué dans l'ensemble des
disciplines vous savez plus on s'élève
plus on s'élève dans la hiérarchie
d'éducation nationale plus on trouve des
personnes qui n'ont plus vu de classe
depuis très longtemps vous dire je ne
comprend pas que les professeurs ne
soient pas capables de prendre en compte
la diversité des élèves dans une même
classe et puis quand on va dans les
salles des profs et qu'on rencontre les
professeurs quel que soi leurs idées
politiques d'ailleurs on s'aperçoiv
qu'il n'en peuvent plus de cette
hétérogénité des classes qui fait queils
sont soit obligés d'abandonner les bons
élèves ceux qui lisent couramment dès la
6e et puis ceux qui sont en très grandes
difficultés il faut qu'ils fassent des
choix et à force de faire des choix
c'est l'ensemble du système qui est en
train sécou vouz le collège unique c'est
une très belle idée mais qui a été
dévoyée c'est une idée qui vient de la
droite cétait le ministre abit qui en
1975 a créé le collège unique le
problème c'est qu'on a transformé peu à
peu le collège unique en collège
uniforme tout le monde de la 6e la 3e
dans la même classe ça ne marche pas
alors que la gauche se campe ainsi dans
des postures idéologiques c'est son
problème si le ministre est pragmatique
il faut qu'il aille jusqu'au bout de ses
déclarations c'est pour toutes les
disciplines la fin du collège uniforme
oui tous les enfants de France doivent
aller en collège jusqu'en 3e mais avec
des parcours différenciés avec des
parcours individualisés et on évitera le
décrochage on évitera le cancer du
système éducatif français actuellement
le décrochage en collège qui se traduit
ensuite par bien des conséquences
désastreuses pour pour les jeunes de ce
pays est-ce qu'il y a pas un risque
quand même de creuser encore plus le
fossé entre les élèves les plus en
difficulté et les meilleurs élèves de
l'autre hier pendant l'audition vous
avez des collègues de gauche qui ont
cité certaines études montrant que et
bien cette mixité ce mélange n'avait pas
de conséquen négatives pour les
meilleurs élèves alors qu'il avait des
conséquences positives à long terme pour
les élèves les plus en difficulté mes
collègues de gauche se trompent les
études les évaluations montrent
actuellement que le niveau baisse en
France pour tous les déciles d'élèves y
compris pour les meilleurs élèves les
résultats des meilleurs élèves
aujourd'hui sont inférieurs à ceux d'il
y a 20 ans et sont inférieurs à la
plupart des comparaisons européennes
donc c'est pas parce que des propos
viennent sur l'éducation de la gauche
qui sont la vérité révélée bien au
contraire ce qu'on dit hier soir mes
collègues de gauche ne répond pas aux
évaluations qui montrent que le niveau
baisse dans toutes les disciplines et
pour tous les Décines d'élèves les
meilleurs les 10 % les meilleurs comme
bien sûr les 10 % les plus mauvais tout
simplement parce qu'il est impossible
pédagogiquement de faire cours en même
temps et de faire travailler ensemble
des élèves en très grande difficulté et
des élèves qui sont parfaite
particulièrement performants moi
j'invite mes collègues qui ont ce
discours là d'aller dans une classe je
leur donne pas 3 jours avant de changer
d'avis l'un des gros problèmes c'est
l'attractivité du métier de professeur
il en a été question hier durant cette
audition Gabriel hatal qui a rappelé
qu'il avait augmenté les professeurs
depuis 1 an il dit nous effaçons en
grande partie une génération de
déclassement salarial pour nos
professeurs là-dessus il a une bonne
politique bien entendu que la
revalorisation salariale est nécessaire
elle a commencé elle n'est pas
suffisante aujourd'hui il y a un effort
de rattrapage de longues années où ce
métier a été déclassé y compris dans des
comparaisons par rapport aux autres
ministères aux autres fonctionnaires il
y a une dégradation de la situation des
professeurs si on le compare à la
plupart des grands corps de la fonction
publque mais elle va assez loin cette
augmentation est-ce qu'il y a pas
notamment un problème pour les
professeurs en milieu de carrière pas
loin il y a une amélioration
particulièrement pour les jeunes
professeurs et c'était nécessaire parce
que les niveaux étaient particulièrement
bas en comparaison européenne
aujourd'hui on a une vraie problématique
au milieu de la carrière simplement ce
que je voudrais vous dire c'est que les
revalorisations salariales sont
nécessaires elles ne sont pas
suffisantes j'ai Mo interrogé le
Ministre hier soir sur la nécessité de
travailler l'entrée dans le métier c'est
le moment où ça craque c'est le moment
où beaucoup de jeunes ne passent pas le
concours ou alors ils démissionnent très
vite après avoir été lauréat du concours
tout simplement parce qu'ils subissent
un véritable bisutage par l'institution
éducation nationale donc il faut revoir
la formation il a parlé de créer des
écoles normales du 21e siècle c'est
c'est un autre sujet mais sur le
bisutage institutionnel pensez que c'est
au moment où vous êtes le plus mal payé
le plus mal formé que vous avez encore
besoin d'apprendre votre métier qu'on
vous envoie travailler dans les
établissements les plus difficiles on
vous envoie dans les tranchées de Verdun
vous faire décaniller proprement après
on s'étonne que des jeunes venus de mon
département n'ai pas envie de se
retrouver ainsi dans un véritable choc
frontal dans des conditions très
difficiles au moment où vous entrez dans
la vie dans la vie professionnelle dans
la vie sentimentale où vous construisez
votre avenir on vous envoie travailler
là où c'est le plus difficile quelle est
la profession quel est le ministère où
les postes les plus difficiles sont
donnés mais quelle est la solution
surtout parce que vous savez très bien
ma question que les profs expérimentés
veent pas y aller dans ces zon ça fait 5
ans que nous la proposons au Sénat cette
solution et hier le ministre a commencé
à en parler moi je suis persuadé qu'avec
un contrat court avec un meilleur
salaire mais aussi la certitude qu'à la
sortie de ce contrat court vous aurez le
poste que vous souhaitez non pas dans 20
ans ou dans 30 ans avec une une gestion
des ressources humaines au barê en
l'Anci é je vais en baver pendant 20 ans
et peut-être que dans 20 ans je
rejoindrai enfin le lycée de Bayonne si
on sort de cette logique si on dit tu
vas travailler parce que tu es formé
parce que tu as les compétences dans un
collège où la République a besoin de toi
mais dans 5 ans tu rejoindras le lycée
que tu souhaites dans la région que tu
souhaites croyez-moi on trouvera à ce
moment-là des volontaes j'en suis
persuadé c'est le contrat c'est un
gagnant gagnant c'est la République qui
dit on a besoin de toi ici mais on s
rappellera le drame de la gestion des
ressources humaines et éducation
nationale c'est qu'il y a pas de mémoire
on continue à à à parler de ce sujet
Samia si vous voulez rester avec nous on
continue à parler de l'audition de
Gabriel àal on en parle avec Jefferson
des sport bonjour Jefferson grand
reporter au journal Sud-Ouest et vous
voulz revenir sur la situation
particulière des écoles
rurales bonjour bonjour Max Brisson hier
au Sénat vous avez donc auditionné
Gabriel le ministre de l'éducation
nationale et vous l'avez interrogé Max
Brisson sur le besoin de visibilité des
écoles rurales et cette urgence à
rénover ce partenariat entre les maires
ruraux l'éducation nationale est-ce que
vous avez bon espoir d'être entendu sur
ce sujet là sachant que les question on
été très nombreuse vous l'avez rappelé
en plateau moi j'ai demandé au ministre
qui a plutôt répondu positivement j'ai
fa d'esport que l'on entre dans une
logique pur annuelle de la politique
d'ouverture et de fermeture des classes
ce qu'on appelle la carte scolaire
aujourd'hui on voit des inspecteurs qui
tous les ans rentrent dans les écoles
pour compte les élèves alors que une
maison est en construction alors qu'une
famille va s'installer l'année suivante
alors queun ltissement est en train
d'être préparer tout cela ne compte pas
c'est au momenté où on ferme où on ouvre
un poste dans en zone urbaine ça pas une
importance dramatique dans une école à
deux classes la fermeture d'une classe
c'est la fin de l'école et quelque part
c'est la fin du village donc il est
urgent que l'éducation nationale entre
au 21e siècle qu'on arrête avec ces
pratiques qui qui date de la 3e
république où chaque année on adapte le
nombre des professeurs au nombre des
élèves comme si dans tous les ministères
on adaptait chaque année le nombre des
fonctionnaires au nombre des usagers
c'est absurde on demande au maire
d'entrer dans des logiques de
construction de documents d'urbanisme à
10 ans à 15 ans avec le zéro
artificiation net on leur parle de 2050
et l'éducation nationale comme autre
fois fait de la comptabilité à l'année
il faut s'inscrire dans une logique
pluriannuelle et dans une logique de
partenariat de dialogue vous savez les M
hésitent aujourd'hui à investir dans les
écoles il y a pourtant nécessité de le
faire parce qu'ils n'ont pas de vision à
moyen terme il est temps que l'éducation
nationale dans les école rurale en
particulier est une vision moyen terme
Jefferson une autre question une
dernière question Max Brisson est-ce que
vous estimez que Gabriel Atal qui n'a
que quelques mois à la tête de
l'éducation nationale a déjà fait
oublier son prédécesseur papend céit
c'estit pas très difficile tellement le
ministre papendag a été absent du S0 rue
de Grenel dont il n'a jamais pris la
mesure il éant que le discours de
Gabriel Atal tranche que ce discours
nous plaît davantage mais comme je le
disais il y a un instant c'est dans aux
actes que nous jugerons et c'est
surpèces que nous jugerons le ministre
et je sens bien par exemple sur les
classes différenciés sur les groupes de
compétences parce qu'il a pas voulu
utiliser le terme de classe de niveau
que entre sa volonté qui est
certainement ferme et la la certitude
qu'il a d'être suivi par sa majorité il
y a un delta donc nous verrons bien s'il
a les moyens politiques de la politique
qu'il annonce merci Jefferson on regarde
la Une de Sud-Ouest maladie MH alerte
sur les fermes c'est à la Une de votre
journal Samia vous nous en parlez tout à
l'heure dans la rue de presse he tout à
fait on va développer tout ça avec vous
merci Jefferson d'avoir été avec nous
merci merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité pendant cette première demi-heure